[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 155 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform podcast.
My name is Mark Mandel, and
I'm here with my colleague.
This week, I am joined by a very
special guest, Michelle Casbon.
How are you doing, Michelle?
MICHELLE CASBON:
I'm doing great.
How are you, Mark?
MARK MANDEL: I'm very well.
Thank you very much for standing
in for Melanie this week,
and joining me on the podcast.
MICHELLE CASBON: It's fantastic
to be here, my first time
co-hosting.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, just like every
week, this week,
we're going to be talking about
an interview with Confluent.
We're going to be talking to
them about Kafka and message
processing systems.
After that, we'll be doing our
question of the week, where
we'll be asking, if
I wanted to submit
a CFP, or a call for papers, for
Next 2019, how would I do it?
MICHELLE CASBON:
How would you do it?
MARK MANDEL: I don't know.
I don't know how I
would do it, but I
believe you have the answer.
MICHELLE CASBON: There are a
lot of answers to that question.
It's well documented
on our website.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
and we'll talk about that.
Before we do that,
we're going to get stuck
into cool things of the week.
And I know you have
some Kubeflow stuff.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yes.
I have lots of really
good Kubeflow news.
So it has been a very
big year for Kubeflow.
It is coming up on its
one year anniversary.
The project was launched
just under a year ago.
This was an action-packed week.
One of my favorite things,
last week we published a guide
to inclusivity.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MICHELLE CASBON: This is a guide
for leaders of the Kubeflow
project.
And it's really pretty generic.
I think it applies to any
open source project, really,
any tech related project.
It's open source.
It's on the GitHub repo at
GitHub.com/kubeflow/community.
It's inclusivity dot markdown.
And it's just a few
examples of things
that we do within the
Kubeflow community
to make sure that
everyone feels welcome.
And it's really
beneficial to, not just
underrepresented groups,
but really for everyone.
MARK MANDEL: Ooh, I
think I'll steal that.
That sounds really good.
MICHELLE CASBON: Please do.
That's why it's
there in open source.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
We'll have a link
in the show notes.
We also have a
really great article
talking about how
"New York Times" is
using Google Cloud to find
untold stories in millions
of archived photos.
So they have a huge
swath of images
from a variety of sources,
and a huge amount of history.
And they're building out
an asset management system
that uses cloud storage,
Pub/Sub, machine learning
through the Vision
API, basically
to take all these
images and catalog them,
and find out all sorts of
interesting stuff in there.
It's actually a
really cool article.
You should check it out.
MICHELLE CASBON:
Yeah, it sounds great.
And didn't they call
this the morgue?
Wasn't this like a
basement full of images
that they're digitizing?
MARK MANDEL: Oh really?
I didn't think
they'd call it that.
That's a delightfully doc name.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yes.
And it's like improving
access to things
inside the morgue, which
everyone gets excited about.
MARK MANDEL: That's wonderful.
MICHELLE CASBON: All right.
So the other cool thing,
so more Kubeflow news,
we just released
something called Clicks
to Deploy, which gives
you everything you need
to get started with Kubeflow.
It helps you to deploy
your whole infrastructure,
and install all of the Kubeflow
files onto a GKE cluster.
And it's just a pretty
simple website--
deploy.kubeflow.cloud.
And type in your project name,
add your OAuth credentials,
boom, you're done.
It takes about 15
minutes to spin up.
It'll give you a domain
name to access everything
inside the cluster.
Much simpler than all
of the very detailed
steps you used to
have to go through.
So again, big news for Kubeflow.
MARK MANDEL: Very nice.
Excellent.
Another cool thing,
I would be remiss
if I didn't talk
about Kubernetes.
So Containerd, which is an
industry standard container
runtime, and basically the core
part of Docker's core runtime
process--
if you want to try Containerd
on Google Kubernetes engine,
it's available for
beta testing now.
Basically, if you want to
just test your workflows,
make sure everything
works the way
it should do, you
can do that basically
by saying there's a
particular Container operating
system, image type, that you
can use inside your GKE startup
scripts.
And that will start
up the beta version
that uses Containerd rather
than the full Docker stack.
So it's got some
nice things about it.
Basically, great fit, but
it's meant to be embedded,
smaller resource footprint,
that kind of stuff.
So if you want to take it for
a spin and see how it works,
it's available for you now.
MICHELLE CASBON: Sounds great.
I promise this is the
last Kubeflow news.
So this was the biggest
news of the week.
And this was an announcement,
a few new things.
One of them is the AI hub,
and the other is Pipelines.
These are important
because it's a way
to interact with Kubeflow that
doesn't involve getting down
to the Kubernetes level and
using kubectl and worrying
about pods.
So Pipelines provides a Python
SDK, gives you a way to,
from within a notebook, to
define an entire machine
learning workflow.
And then there's a
really nice fancy UI
so that you can see things
running and see the status.
You can view your pod logs from
within this really nice UI.
And then the AI Hub
is where you can
find sort of generic components
to bring into your pipeline
to make it easier to
start from scratch
with a few pre-baked things.
And those are both public
objects and private.
So if you're within
an organization,
you can have things just
for you and your group.
So lots of room
for growth there.
It's brand new.
It just opened up.
I believe it's in alpha release.
So if you want to get
started, I believe there's
a link to sign up for that.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
And finally, this is
something that I've actually
really wanted for a
really, really long time,
and I'm so glad to see it.
Cloud Scheduler is available.
So basically, if you've
ever wanted to run anything
on Google Cloud Platform
on a regular basis
without having to start
up a VM with Cron,
or just to create a
simple App Engine app just
to do Cron scripting, we now
have a thing that does this,
and it's really good.
So it's a job scheduler.
You set it up-- it actually
uses the same Chrome tab-type
format.
But basically, if you want
to push an event to an HTTP
endpoint or to
Pub/Sub, and you want
to do it on a regular
basis, you can now
do it through Cloud Scheduler.
And you can go play with
it now, and it works,
and it does cool stuff.
So no more having to build these
little App Engine apps just
to do Cron stuff.
MICHELLE CASBON: Nice.
So you can upload your
asterisk commands directly
to the Cloud
scheduler, and not have
to worry about building
a whole app around it.
MARK MANDEL: Nope.
You have to build the whole app.
It's just a little
thing that does
the thing it's supposed to do.
MICHELLE CASBON: Nice.
Is there a good
GUI for it, or do I
have to still speak
in asterisk language?
MARK MANDEL: There
is a GUI for it.
So you can do that
in there, as well.
The frequency is still in
asterisk language in Crontab,
but we have guides
for that, as well.
MICHELLE CASBON: Wonderful.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's not too bad.
Awesome.
So why don't we go
chat with Viktor
about Confluent and Kafka?
MICHELLE CASBON: Sounds great.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do it.
Thanks so much to Viktor Gamov
for coming to join us today,
developer advocate
for Confluent.
Viktor, how are you doing?
VIKTOR GAMOV: Hi, guys.
Very excited to be here.
Longtime listener,
first time caller.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS] I think,
actually, you're the first one
to make that joke.
Excellent.
Well, thanks so
much for coming down
to talk to us about
Confluent and Kafka.
Before we get stuck into that,
tell us about who you are,
and what do you do?
VIKTOR GAMOV: I'm a developer
advocate at Confluent.
What I do, I like to talk
to developers, engineers,
administrators, architects,
about Kafka and streaming
platform.
It's very short, but we
can dive deeper if needed.
MICHELLE CASBON: So can
you tell us, what is Kafka?
VIKTOR GAMOV: Prepared
question, right?
MICHELLE CASBON: No, not at all.
None of this ever is prepared.
VIKTOR GAMOV: [LAUGHS] Yeah.
Essentially, Kafka is what
we call streaming platform.
And interesting enough that,
when you talk to people,
it depends on who
you're talking to.
If you're talking to people who
have a messaging background,
they can feel that, oh, it looks
like new messaging solution.
If you talk to people who
have a databases background,
they might say, oh, it looks
like distributed database,
because of the nature of the
data that we're putting there.
So Kafka is a very
unique beast in the world
of distributive systems.
But essentially what we call
it is a streaming platform
that allows you to not only
consume results in real time,
but also do processing.
Because usually Kafka
is Apache project,
includes multiple things--
that brokers itself,
stream processing library
called Kafka Streams,
and the library
that allows to easy
integration with data sources
called Kafka Connect.
So this is a very short
version, but again, we
can go as deep as
you want, and as deep
as your listeners want to.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
So what sort of things do
people tend to use Kafka for?
I mean, you mentioned that some
people think of it in one way,
and other people think
of it in another.
What are some typical use cases?
VIKTOR GAMOV: When the
Kafka was developed back
in the day on the
LinkedIn, they tried
to solve one of the
problems to increase speed
of data ingestion
into Hadoop, and they
started to move from the
batch-oriented pipelines, where
they need to wait until
all data will arrive
into some like LinkedIn
area where they can start
processing, to the more
like, OK, do we really
need to wait for all this data?
Because our algorithms not
necessarily need to have in one
place.
So we can do this and process
this data as it comes.
So this is where idea of stream
processing, and essentially
infinite stream of data that
comes into the system, where
we can process this
data as it comes instead
of having this buffer,
or after that we can
process at the end of the day.
So this is one of
the use case, where
the people start using this
in a very limited capacity.
They started, OK, so if we
will stream our logs there,
because usually logs--
it's important data, but
it's not that important.
There's actual transactional
data, and so far and so on.
So the log processing
was one of the use cases
where people started
to look into Kafka.
Over the time, people
start realizing
that, hey, actually
we can use it
to solving some of the real-time
use cases, where we have data
that comes in the big amounts
and the high velocity,
so the Kafka helps
to absorb this.
So Kafka behaves as
an actual buffer.
Plus, libraries allows to
process data as it arrives.
Now, use cases around Kafka
pretty much are limitless.
Kafka even used like a back
bone for microservices,
when you need to
establish communication
between different microservices
components without actually
tightly coupling them.
MICHELLE CASBON:
How does it buffer?
Like, can you give us
just a conceptual idea
of what that really means?
VIKTOR GAMOV: So Kafka itself
represents data structure
that called append-only log,
or distributed append-only log,
meaning that data
always will be reading
to the end of the file, which
allows to very fast write
capabilities, and also
can be read sequentially.
So all consumers read the data
from beginning of the file,
and they read this sequentially.
That also allows very fast
speed in terms of consumption.
This is why Kafka
looks like or sounds
like a messaging
queue for many people,
because in messaging
queue, your messages
comes from one place and
reading from another end, right?
So it's like a
first-in, first-out type
of data structure.
So this is why it's also
suitable for messaging
use cases.
Kafka provides the ways how
this data can be replicated,
in case of one of the
brokers will go down,
provides the way
how these topics--
what we call topics, data
structure where everyone
is reading and writing.
And the topics allows us to--
topic is partition.
So this is why,
when I was talking
about data structures that
lies inside the Kafka,
they remind some NoSQL
type of database, where
you can have a
horizontal scalability,
and you can scale your topics
by just adding more brokers.
And essentially it provides also
replicas in case of failures.
MARK MANDEL: Are there
any kinds of limits
and the type of information
that can go into Kafka,
or is it kind of just like,
throw whatever you want in
there to get processed?
VIKTOR GAMOV: Essentially
there is no limit.
But conceptually, there is.
So as a streaming
platform, Kafka
is designed to be handling
large number of messages.
But the size of messages
should be relatively small.
So this is why, if you're
trying to stream files,
like 100 megabytes of
file as one message, maybe
it's not very suitable.
So this is why people come up
with different workarounds,
so that they still
can use this use case
or want to implement
this use case.
So you can chunk this file and
send this in different chunks.
Probably, if we're
talking about streaming,
people usually talking about
streaming video or streaming
audio.
So Kafka is not
specifically a good case
for that kind of payload.
So I would say, a large number
of messages, high velocity,
this is the perfect
type of payload.
But inside the
message, it really
doesn't matter what
you put in there.
MICHELLE CASBON: So data
is, of course, key nowadays.
And being able to manage it,
of course, is very important.
Where does Kafka
plug in in terms
of integrating the various
data, tooling, and products
that exist out there?
What are all the things
it integrates into?
VIKTOR GAMOV: The major use
case, what I see right now--
I used to work in the
professional services
of Confluent.
So I was talking to many
customers about their use cases
and the things how
they want to use it.
And specifically when we're
talking about data integration,
change data capture use
case is on the high demand.
So imagine you have things
like Oracle database,
where you want to
extract the changes
and make them real-time.
So when we're talking about
usual traditional databases,
it's kind of like a
solid source of data.
But we want to provide a
little bit of fluidity.
We need to start
moving data out.
So having these connectors that
was written using Kafka Connect
framework, can
extract this or listen
to changes that happen
in Oracle database,
and push these
changes into Kafka.
So once you broke this silo
of your Oracle database,
your data becomes
available for many sources.
So Kafka designed to
be very heavy on reads.
This is why you have this
kind of literature allusion
to-- the Franz Kafka
is a famous writer.
So when someone wrote this once,
and many people can read this.
So same thing with Kafka.
So once you extract
this data from this data
silo as a traditional
relational database
and start moving data
out, in this case
you open up multiple different
possibilities for integration.
Connectors can be two types.
One can bring data in, and
another can take data out.
So once you extracted
this from Oracle,
you can do processing in Kafka
using Kafka Streams or KSQL,
and after that offload this data
to Mongo, to Elastic, or even
to any cloud storage.
One of the use case
that we see right now
is making Kafka as a--
I don't want to
sound too marketing,
but it's kind of like
a bridge to cloud.
I'm sorry about that.
But essentially,
one of the company
that I was working, instead of
paying vendors to provide them
ways how they can do
replication, and that
was going to be very expensive.
They use Kafka CDC
to change the capture
of their on-prem database, and
replicate it to their Google
Cloud Platform instances.
MARK MANDEL: So if someone
needs to build a connector,
or they want to build their
own custom integration,
is there APIs or
client libraries
for different languages?
How does that work?
VIKTOR GAMOV:
Usually what I tried
to say, before you start
building something--
and short answer to
your question, yes.
But before you start
building something,
you need to check if there is
a connector already available.
Because the framework
itself, it's
quite popular for
building connectors.
There is one common place where
everyone can go and publish
their connectors
called Confluent Hub.
So if you go to
Confluent.io/hub,
you will find all
possible connectors.
MARK MANDEL: OK, cool.
VIKTOR GAMOV: If you
want to build this,
it will require some of
the skills, specifically
Java skills.
So if you want to
build a connector,
there is a framework,
Kafka Connect,
there's documentation
around this.
There's some examples of
how to build connector.
I would say it's fairly simple.
Like, I built a
connector myself.
So I can say that I'm not
the brightest engineer,
or the smartest engineer.
I can build connector, so
everyone can build connector.
So API is quite straightforward.
You just need to
figure out how you
want to read data out of
Kafka or write data to Kafka,
and that's pretty much it.
However, if you don't
want to, for some reason,
learn Java, or API for
your data source is not
available for
Java, you can still
stick to traditional
producer-consumer clients.
There are plenty
native integration
for any possible language.
So Java, .NET,
[INAUDIBLE],, C#, C++.
Just tell me when
I need to stop.
MICHELLE CASBON: All the things.
OK.
So I understand that there is
an open source version of Kafka,
and there's also an
enterprise version.
So what makes them different,
and what makes them the same?
VIKTOR GAMOV: So I would say
this is not a very precisely
accurate statement, because
Kafka itself is open source.
There's no enterprise
version of Kafka.
So what we do in Confluent,
we actually building streaming
platform that augments basic
things that provides by Kafka--
brokers, clients, Kafka
Connect, and Kafka
streams, with some
additional capabilities
that enterprises need.
So this is why we
build two things,
we build the Confluent platform
open source and the Confluent
enterprise.
So for open source
platform, we include
things for managing
schema for that,
managing metadata
around this data
called Schema
Registry, that allows
you to have a
centralized place where
we can store all of
these schemas of the data
and provide different
versions, so one microservice
can not have this data like
some built-in application.
They can always request
this from Schema Registry.
We provide a REST proxy, which
is, in very rare occasion,
where you cannot
use native clients,
you can use a REST proxy.
So for example, you're
writing Kafka client in BASH,
and you're using cURL
to interact with Kafka.
So you can use a REST
proxy to do that.
And the third one, I
guess, very cool thing,
is the KSQL, which is
stream processing tool that
allows you to use SQL to
write your stream processing
applications.
MARK MANDEL: How do you write
SQL to do stream processing?
How does that work?
VIKTOR GAMOV: So we
were thinking that, OK,
how we can liberate
the stream processing
and open up to a wider audience.
And we figured out that the
most used language, or most
used technology, in
data world is SQL.
So we said, OK, let's see
how we can use a SQL language
as a DSL for stream processing.
So essentially, we took
some of the concept
that people already
know-- do your select,
and you filtering by
in-particular fields,
and we build a tool called KSQL.
So you have an infinite stream
of credit card transactions,
but you're only
interested in data
that happened with one account
within five-second interval,
so you have multiple swipes.
So you can potentially
say, OK, so maybe it's
a fraudulent account within
five-second interval.
So KSQL allows you to
write simple SQL statement
on infinite stream of
data that will produce
another stream that will
include all the data that you're
interested.
So for example, from the stream
of credit card transactions,
we can produce
stream that will have
potential fraudulent
transactions, that will include
all messages where credit
card number ID will
be swiped three
times or five times
within five-minute interval.
So it is a powerful
thing, because it includes
what we call stateful stream
processing, because in order
to do a count, how many times
you swiped a credit card,
you need to have a result from
the previous message, right?
So you need to have
it stored somewhere.
You need to have a state.
And also, you need
to have a state that
will be applicable to a
particular time window.
Window is essentially
a concept that
allows you to build
finite data chunks
on infinite stream of data.
And everything was done
thanks to Kafka Stream.
So KSQL is built onto Kafka
Streams, which is Java library.
But as a developer,
you don't need
to learn Java or
any other language.
Just use SQL to write
your application.
I am not sure if I
answered this fully,
but essentially, there's
a couple extensions
that you need to know,
because in standard SQL
there is no stream concept.
There's no window concept.
However, if you want to
[INAUDIBLE],, for example,
you have data that
comes with the stream,
and you have some data that you
extracted from your database,
and this data inside the Kafka.
You can join those
two streams in order
to produce enriched stream.
You have a stream that only
includes credit card number
information, and have another
stream that has credit card
number and all fields
that is required
to know who the owner
of the credit card, what
is the balance, and
things like that.
So you're joining
two streams in order
to produce third stream, which
would be augmented stream.
And to quickly return to the
question about enterprise
platform-- so enterprise
platform includes
some of the monitoring
tools, some advanced tools
for data replication,
and essentially it's
also built on top of
open source Kafka,
on top of open source
platform, and provides
some of the enterprise
tools like for monitoring,
for example, control
center, and some
of the connectors for
enterprise systems.
But Kafka itself, it's
fully open source.
And there's no difference
between enterprise platform
and open source Kafka.
MICHELLE CASBON: Great.
So what is the relationship
between Confluent and the Kafka
project?
VIKTOR GAMOV: So
the Confluent was
founded by three people
that came from LinkedIn,
and those people were
active contributors
to Apache Kafka project.
So Jay Kreps was one of
the masterminds behind some
of the distributed
systems in LinkedIn,
and the Kafka was included.
And one of the most
popular project is Kafka.
So he helped to bring this to
Apache Software Foundation.
And after that, when the project
was very popular in Apache,
they decided to start a company
to provide streaming platform
on top of Apache
Kafka that will have
all features of
open source thing,
but also will have
advanced features
and tools that modern
enterprise require,
for example, like for data
governance and schema registry,
or for providing simplicity
of stream processing,
providing KSQL,
so far and so on.
So right now, I don't
remember exact number,
but Confluent is the
largest contributor
to open source Apache Kafka.
So we have engineers who
work on pushing the bits
and bytes to Apache Kafka.
MARK MANDEL: So this is the
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
What's the relationship
between Confluent and Google
Cloud at the moment?
VIKTOR GAMOV: I would
say, maybe two years ago,
we would start getting
a lot of requests
from customers saying that, hey,
so it would be great if there
would be a managed to Kafka--
I'm sorry.
I'm starting from a
little bit of history
to put some of the
context in place.
So the customer was
saying, yeah, it
would be great to
have managed Kafka,
because we as enterprises
want to focus on getting fast
into cloud, and getting fast
into solving our business
problems rather than
building infrastructure.
So we start building what we
call the Confluent Cloud, which
is essentially a fully
managed solution for running
not only Apache Kafka, but
full Confluent platform.
So one of the things
that we had in mind
is that we don't want
people manage anything.
You don't need to give us
your account information
if you want ours to
run on your hardware.
So we can say, yes, we can
run Kafka and the Confluent
platform in any public cloud
provider, so pick and choose.
So we released
everything in AWS,
and last year was huge
success of launch,
a long-awaited launch of
Confluent Cloud in the Google
Cloud Platform.
Some of the things
that we initially
built for this
platform was we're
architected to support
running into multiple cloud
environments, for example.
So essentially, we run
everything in Kubernetes.
So Kubernetes is our
weapon of choice.
MICHELLE CASBON: Mark's doing
a happy dance about Kubernetes.
VIKTOR GAMOV: Keep this,
the Kubernetes thing,
on the back burner.
We have some news
around this, as well.
When we move to
another cloud from AWS,
we actually had to
rearchitect other things,
because lot of things
were easy to do in AWS,
some of the things were
easy to do in Google Cloud.
For example, like to spin
up the Kubernetes class,
that is much easier in
the Google Cloud Platform.
Or to configure
some of the things--
because simply it
was more popular,
AWS has some certain API
to do load balancing.
But right now, it's a parity.
So when you go to
Confluent Cloud,
and you want to spin up your
Kafka, you can say, hey,
I want to run this
in my Google Cloud.
You can just select the
region, and after that you're
good to go.
So you don't need to think
where this is running.
You just have a connection
stream to Kafka,
and that's pretty much it.
Another thing that I
mentioned about the Kubernetes
is that we internally
gain a lot of experience
by running this at scale.
And some of the customers, like
more conservative customers,
are saying, hey yeah,
the cloud is cool,
but how I would have these same
things that cloud provides,
but also internally.
So we have internal tasks.
For example, we're
running something
like open source
Kubernetes, or when
it will be available publicly,
we can run a GCP on-prem.
How we can run the Kafka
same way as you do.
So that's why we also invested
to product called the Confluent
Operator that allows you to
just deal with your requirements
about Kafka.
You don't need to think about
what's the StatefulSet, what's
your service, what's the
headless service, how
to expose your Kafka
to outside world,
how to build load balance
or [INAUDIBLE] operator
inside Kubernetes, will do same
thing as it does in our cloud,
but it allows the customers to
run this in their data center
on-prem or in cloud.
MARK MANDEL: I literally
just looked at the website.
It says here, "available soon."
Is that all you can say?
VIKTOR GAMOV: Yeah.
It will be available
hopefully the beginning
of the year, 2019.
So right now, we
onboard a few customers,
we run very rigorous
early-access program.
We're running some
of the edge cases
to make sure that product
would meet all expectations.
I already started
playing with this myself.
I also presented this
in a few conferences.
It looks pretty awesome.
In order to provide
the best experience,
we just need to have
a little more testing
with some of our partners
and some of the customers.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
VIKTOR GAMOV: Yeah.
Personally, again, no
one paid me for this,
but I personally use
GCP for all my tests,
because again, right now
it's the best experience,
if you want to have Kubernetes
in public cloud, is GCP.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
VIKTOR GAMOV: So love
it, use it personally.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
It sounds like you're
building some amazing stuff.
What can we expect from Kafka
and Confluent in the future?
I mean, you mentioned
the operators,
but is there any other neat
stuff coming in the pipeline
that people might
want to know about?
VIKTOR GAMOV: Hoo, this
is a very good question.
So we still continue
to pushing boundaries
of what the KSQL can do,
some advanced semantics
supporting some advanced schema.
So right now, KSQL allows you
to, without any interference,
KSQL allows to deal with JSON,
Avro, and [INAUDIBLE],, some
of the comma-separated data.
We're thinking to have more
schemas coming, for example,
gRPC and the Google Protocol
Buffers, that's very
popular formatting services.
We're thinking to support
this, and we have a lot
of requests from the customers.
In terms of cloud,
we keep pushing
some of the observability
elements in the Confluent
Cloud, providing metrics you
can see, how fast this data is
going through, what's
the all possible metrics
that your application
can depend on?
We planning to have full
managed Confluent platform,
all bits and bytes of Confluent
platform will be in our cloud.
And most importantly,
we're planning
to have free tier for
our Kafka As a Service.
So when you want to
start learning things,
you don't need to have data
center to spin up this.
You just go there,
run your Kafka,
grab some of the libraries.
My team is responsible
for helping developers
to have enough examples, to have
enough documentation in order
to start with Kafka.
And we're actually
pretty excited when
we will release free
version of Cloud,
so we can talk more about
libraries, languages.
I'm pretty excited to talk
about Go Client myself.
I start Go Development recently.
MARK MANDEL: Yay!
MICHELLE CASBON: That's great.
If I wanted to contribute to
actually building out Kafka,
since it's open source,
how can I do that?
VIKTOR GAMOV: So if you want
to contribute to Apache Kafka,
it's great that the products
like Kafka and Hadoop,
they're placed in a
well-established software
foundation that has certain
rules about how you do things.
And there's actually very clear
ways how you can contribute.
You start by finding
some issues in Jira.
Jira is public.
You can go, there's
Kafka Jira in Apache,
you start looking
for some issues.
You can go there,
comment saying, hey,
I'm interested to
fix this problem.
So you start working on the
thing, either providing patch,
or you're creating pull
requests, because development
also happen in GitHub.
So there is Apache
mirror of repository,
so you can also do
development in GitHub.
So you're providing your patch.
You discuss through code review,
you discuss with contributors.
One of the contributors
or committers,
they can be your guide, so they
can explain what you're doing,
if everything is
OK, everyone is OK,
so your pull request
will be merged.
So over time you will
gain more and more power
as a [? contributor ?] that
you can become a committer,
and you can start to
send more patches.
And over the time, you
can even start your own,
if you want to introduce
some new feature,
introduce some new
piece of functionality,
you can start your own, called
a Kafka Improvement Proposal,
or KIP, where you can
discuss some of the design
decision or some new features.
And a cool thing
about, usually people
are also asking me, if I
want to learn some internals,
if I want to learn how
different functionality works,
how I can learn this?
And you can go and
read certain KIPs,
because KIP is
essentially your blueprint
for certain functionality,
like a very cool way how
you can learn from the source.
And the thought
process, there's also
some of the design decisions
that were rejected also
mentioned.
It's also pretty cool.
If you want to contribute to
Confluent open source platform,
or like KSQL, it's less strict.
So essentially, go there, for
KSQL, send your pull request,
you will discuss with
engineers, and you just
need to sign contributor
agreement, and pretty much it.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
If people want to learn more
about Kafka or Confluent,
where should they go?
VIKTOR GAMOV: So I
would say they need
to go just the Confluent.io.
And we're working
right now, probably
you should expect this
in 2019 somewhere,
we're working on
some landing page
for developers, the
architects, and administrators.
But right now, Confluent.io,
it's a great landing page.
I would highly recommend
to subscribe to our blog.
Trying to share not only our
success stories, but also some
of the customers, they
contribute to our blog.
Some of the individual
contributors,
they also write for us.
So our blog, you can see
there's like very good source
of all sorts of information,
starting from some internals
about Kafka.
So June Rao is one of the
co-founders of Confluent,
and one of the core
committers of Kafka.
He has a very famous
blog about how
to choose number of partitions.
And even Google, when
you do a Google search,
you will find this
blog faster than you
will find actual documentation.
So it's a very popular and
highly-regarded blog post.
We have interesting use
cases from some customers.
One of the popular blog posts
is from "New York Times,"
and how they use Kafka to
store all the data, or all
the published materials that
they have on their website,
they stored inside a Kafka
topic, so also pretty cool.
And you looking into Google,
some of the use cases,
and most likely you will end
up on the Confluent blog.
I would say, the
best place to start.
MICHELLE CASBON: Great.
Viktor, thank you so
much for coming on.
Is there anything
else that you wanted
to cover before we let you go?
VIKTOR GAMOV: Oh, thank you
so much for having me here.
It was super excited
from my side.
Thanks to you, you
came well prepared
with all the questions.
Hopefully I answered those.
One of the things
that I want to mention
is that we do run a
community Slack channel.
So inside this,
you can go there,
you have multiple rooms
in different topics.
If you want to talk
about Kubernetes,
if you want to talk
about dump containers,
about stream processing,
we do have dedicated there,
where not only our engineers
hang out sometimes, but also
you have a power of community.
We have over a couple
thousand people there.
Maybe not at the same
time, but at least there
is a place where you
can browse some history,
find some answers,
ask questions,
and things like that.
I think this is a great place.
And specifically, if you want
to have some in-person presence,
we also have this
chat room called
Events, where we
publish all meetups that
happen around the
Kafka, around streaming,
all different events.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Well, Viktor, yeah, thank
you so much for joining
us, and talking to us
about Kafka and Confluent.
VIKTOR GAMOV: Thank
you very much.
MICHELLE CASBON: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: So thank you very
much to Viktor, joining us
today to talk to us about Kafka.
MICHELLE CASBON: About
"Kaf-ka" or "Kahf-ka?"
MARK MANDEL: What is the
correct pronunciation?
I don't--
MICHELLE CASBON: I
always say "Kahf-ka."
That's what my friend Gwen
Shapiro always tells me.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
MICHELLE CASBON: I trust
Gwen's pronunciation
of her own company's product.
ANNOUNCER: Pronounced
"Kahf-ka," like "cough drops,"
or "coffee."
MARK MANDEL: That seems
pretty reasonable.
That's what, this is what
happens when you only
see things on the
internet, and you
don't know whether
or not they're
real things in real life.
MICHELLE CASBON: You should meet
Gwen if you ever have a chance.
She's lovely.
MARK MANDEL: I
would be delighted.
Wonderful.
Would they like to
come on the podcast?
MICHELLE CASBON: Oh, perhaps
I could convince her.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS] Excellent.
Anyway, moving along.
We talked about Kafka,
and thank you so
much to Viktor for joining us.
MICHELLE CASBON: Much better.
MARK MANDEL: There we go.
Let's get stuck into our
question of the week.
So I do hear that Cloud
Next 2019 is coming up,
and I would really like
to submit something
so that I can present.
So is there a call for papers?
Can I submit?
How do I do this?
MICHELLE CASBON: There is.
There's a whole website.
You can find the link
in the show notes.
There's a ton of
information on this page.
So this will be
my first Next CFP.
And so I, just this
weekend, was looking
over all of the guidelines,
tips and tricks.
So I will share some of the,
I think, most useful advice.
So the first thing you
want to keep in mind
is that it's not
really about just
describing some cool
project that you've done.
You want to focus on what
people can get out of your talk.
So what are the main things that
they will learn after they've
visited your session?
This is how you draw people in.
This is how you
make it compelling.
And you want to focus
on either a beginner
level, intermediate,
or advanced,
but be very clear about
what you'll be covering
and how many prerequisites
are involved.
So the word counts
are actually pretty
short on this, which I
appreciate, especially
as someone who--
MARK MANDEL: It drives me nuts.
I can't stop but
write long things.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yes, you are
pretty bad about following
the word count limits.
But this one, it's like 250
words for your abstract.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, my.
MICHELLE CASBON:
It's really short.
But that makes it a
lot easier and harder
to submit your abstract.
MARK MANDEL: I'm terrified.
MICHELLE CASBON: So you
want to be very efficient
with your words, like high
impact, heavy hitting, what
are you going to teach?
What are the big takeaways?
MARK MANDEL: When
I write abstracts,
I have a formula
that I like to use
that I think has
worked reasonably well,
which is, what is the problem?
What is the solution?
And then, in this talk,
what are you going to show?
And I find that works
reasonably well.
So like, in some planets,
you can't pet dogs.
[DOG BARKING]
So today we're going to talk
about how we can bring dogs
to your planet.
In this talk, we'll talk about
bringing dogs to planets,
and the problems
you may run into.
Like, that is literally
what my abstracts look like.
MICHELLE CASBON: Nice.
So you're hoping to
draw on people who
live on planets with no dogs.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
MICHELLE CASBON: And it's
there in the abstract.
It's very clear.
They know exactly that they
belong in that session.
MARK MANDEL: And they
know exactly what
they're going to get out of it.
I find that-- that's a formula
I've used a lot over the years.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah,
that's a good model.
And if you want to see
examples of abstracts
that have been accepted,
there's a whole PDF
with about a dozen examples
for you to use as a guide.
And so whatever subject area
you think is most interesting--
preferably it has a
Google product in it.
It is a Google conference.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah.
So you have about a
month to submit this.
Deadline is December 7.
So get your ideas together, and
make sure you get it in time.
But again, it's only 250
words, so there's not
a whole lot of effort
involved in submitting.
And who knows, maybe
it'll get accepted,
and we'll see you
there in April.
MARK MANDEL: That
would be lovely.
Awesome.
Well, where are you going to be?
What are you up to?
What events are you
up to, Michelle?
MICHELLE CASBON: Let's see.
This week, so Friday is--
I think Wednesday, Thursday,
and Friday is Scale By the Bay.
So on Friday, I will be
at a panel, an AI and data
engineering panel.
So you can find me there.
I'll be there with a
couple of my good friends--
Pete Skomoroch
and Lukas Biewald,
a couple of other people.
So if you're at Scale By
the Bay, come find me.
I'll be talking-- what else?
MICHELLE AND MARK
MANDEL: Kubeflow.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
And I believe you're also
traveling down to Australia?
MICHELLE CASBON: That's right.
So just after Thanksgiving
I'll be leaving for Sydney,
and I'll be involved in
a conference called YOW!
I'll be giving a
talk on, what else?
MARK MANDEL: Kubeflow.
MICHELLE CASBON: Kubeflow.
And so I'll be in Sydney, and
then a few days later I'll
be traveling to Brisbane,
and then Melbourne.
So if you're in any
of those three cities,
please come find me.
It'll be great to say hello.
MARK MANDEL: Shout out to
all my Australian friends,
you should totally
listen to Michelle.
MICHELLE CASBON: Absolutely.
Everyone, Kubeflow is a
very interesting topic,
and I make it very intriguing,
because I talk about how
it's like a paper airplane.
MARK MANDEL: Oh,
that sounds good.
Now I want to hear.
MICHELLE CASBON: You should.
MARK MANDEL: So I
know you're also
going to be at KubeCon with me.
What are you going
to be talking about?
MICHELLE CASBON: What else?
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS]
MICHELLE CASBON: I will be
giving a workshop on Kubeflow,
end-to-end Kubeflow.
So pretty beginner, take
you through the installation
process, and a basic training,
serving, UI prediction,
and giving you a code lab.
So a full workshop, giving you
an environment to run it in,
hands on.
Our colleague Amy and I will
both be doing that together.
I keep going.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, I will also be there
talking about Agones, and game
servers, and that kind
of fun stuff as well.
MICHELLE CASBON: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, Michelle, thank
you for joining me
this week on today's podcast.
MICHELLE CASBON: It
was great to be here.
I look forward to
many more with you.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
And thank you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]